you've said that we are much less
violent than our close living relatives
the chimps
can you elaborate on this point
of how violent we are and how violent
our evolutionary relatives are
well i haven't said exactly that we're
less violent than chimps what i've said
is that there are two kinds of violence
one stems from proactive aggression and
the other stems from reactive aggression
proactive aggression is planned
aggression reactive aggression is
impulsive defensive it's reactive
because uh it takes place in
seconds after the threat
and the thing that is really striking
about humans compared to
our close relatives
is the great reduction in the degree of
of reactive aggression
so we are far less violent than chimps
when
prompted by some relatively minor threat
within our own society and the way i
judge that
is um with not super satisfactory data
but
the
the study which is particularly striking
is
one of
people living as
hunter-gatherers in
a really
upsetting kind of environment namely
people in australia uh living in a place
where
they got a lot of alcohol abuse
uh there's a lot of domestic violence
uh it's all uh a sort of
a a society that is um
you know as bad from the point of view
of violence as
an ordinary society can get
there's excellent data on the frequency
with which people actually have physical
violence and hit each other and we can
compare that to
data from
several different sites comparing we're
looking at chimpanzee and bonobo
violence
and the
difference is between two and three
orders of magnitude the frequency with
which chimps and bonobos hit each other
chase each other charge each other
physically engage
is something between 500 and a thousand
times
higher than in humans so there's
something just amazing about us and you
know this has been recognized for for
centuries uh aristotle drew attention to
the fact that we behave in many ways
like domesticated animals because we're
so unviolent
but you know people say well what about
you know the hideous engagements of this
20th century
the the first and second world war and
and much else besides
and uh that is all proactive violence
you know all of that is is gangs of
people
uh
making deliberate decisions to go off an
attack
in circumstances which ideally uh the
attackers are going to be able to make
their kills and then get out of there
in other words not
face confrontation that's the ordinary
way that arm is trying to work
and
and there
it turns out that humans and chimpanzees
are in a very similar kind of state that
is to say if you look at the
the rate of death from chimpanzees
conducting proactive coalitionary
violence
it's very similar in many ways to what
you see in humans
so when not down regulated with
proactive violence it's just this
reactive violence that is
strikingly reduced in humans
so chimpanzees also practice kind of
tribal warfare
indeed they do yeah
so this was discovered first in 1974 it
was observed first 974
which was about the time that
um the
first major study of chimpanzees in the
wild by jane goodall
had been going for
something like five years
during
of
the chimpanzees being observed wherever
they went
until then they'd been observed
at a feeding station where jane was
luring them into
to be observed by seeing bananas which
is great
she learned a lot but she didn't learn
what was happening at the edges of their
ranges
so five years later
it became
very obvious that there was hostile
relationships between groups
and those hostile relationships
sometimes
take the form of the kind of hostile
relationships that you see in many
animals which is a bunch of um
chimps in this case uh
shouting
at a bunch of other chimps
on their borders
but dramatically in addition to that
there is a second kind of interaction
and that is
when
a a party of chimpanzees
makes a
deliberate venture uh to the edge of
their territory
silently
and then
search for members of neighboring groups
and what they're searching for is a lone
individual
so i've been with chimps when they've
heard a lone individual under these
circumstances
or what they think is a lone one
and they touch each other and look at
each other and then charge forward very
excited
um
and then
while they're charging
all of a sudden
the place where they heard a loan call
erupts with a volley of calls it was
just one calling out of a larger party
and our chimps put on the brakes and
scoot back for safety into their own
territory but if in fact they do find a
lone individual and they they can sneak
up to them
then they make a deliberate attack
they're hunting
they're stalking and hunting and and
then they impose terrible damage which
typically ends in a kill straight away
but it might end up with the victim
so damaged that they'll they'll crawl
away and die a few days
or hours later
so that was a very dramatic discovery
because it really
made people
realize for the first time that conrad
lorenz had been wrong when in the 1960s
in his famous book on aggression he said
warfare is restricted to humans animals
do not deliberately kill each other well
now we know that actually there's a
bunch of animals that deliberately kill
each other and they always do so under
essentially the same circumstances which
is
when they feel safe doing it
so humans feel safe doing it when they
got a weapon
animals
feel safe when they have a coalition
a coalition that has overwhelming power
compared to the victim and so wolves
will do that and lions will do that and
hyenas will do that and chimpanzees will
do it and and humans do it too
can they pull themselves
into something that looks more like a
symmetric war as opposed to an
asymmetric one so accidentally engaging
on the lone individual and getting
themselves into trouble and then
a warfare breaks out or
or or you think you have a battle a
battle yeah are they more aggressive in
avoiding these kinds of battles no
they're very very keen to avoid those
kinds of battles but occasionally
they can make a mistake
but
so far
there have been no observations of
anything like a battle in which both
sides maintain themselves and
i think you can very confidently say
that
overwhelmingly what happens is that if
they discover that there's several
individuals on the other side then both
sides retreat
nobody wants to get hurt
what they want to do is to hurt others
you